brought with me the Omni
4155 pages
when was it produced in the dead of the
night 1 30 in the morning when it was
released
now people argue that it's
conservative's fault what is more
dangerous what is more dangerous to the
country
1.1 trillion dollars in new debt or is
Republican leadership likes to say oh
but it's a win it's a big win we're
getting 45 billion dollars for the
military so which is more important
I think the greatest risk to our
national security is our debt the
process stinks it's an Abomination it's
a no-good rotten way to run your
government it's like he's kind of like
the same guy who accidentally got thrown
into the mental institution right so
everyone in DC Republicans who they're
all just awful everyone does all the
wrong things like they just don't care
nobody nobody is willing to take the
slings and hours and I'm talking at the
Federal